[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le succès de la série le jeu
de la dame sur netflix il confirmant
ensuite ont décuplé l'intérêt pour les
échecs dans le monde entier s'il y a
quelqu'un qui en a profité c'est bien
kevin bord dix joueurs très peu mais
très prometteur quand il était
adolescent il a été le précurseur du
live streaming pour les échecs et sa
chaîne bitstream et la chaîne numéro un
sur les échecs en france elle vient
d'attendre les 30 millions de vues je
profite donc qu'il vient de publier avec
samir aux et au bec
un excellent livre d'apprentissage
gagner aux échecs même quand on débute
pour lui consacrer toute une émission va
pouvoir parler pendant près d'une heure
du roi des jeux et du jeu des rois avec
l'un de ses meilleurs spécialistes et
l'aborder sous tous les angles
l'influencent d'internet des ordinateurs
l'arrivée des femmes
est-ce que c'est utile dans la vie de
tous les jours de jouer aux échecs
est-ce que ça rend plus intelligent est
ce que ça rend méchant mais d'abord on
commence comme à chaque fois par une
image symbolisant notre époque voici
celle que vous avez choisi alors
pourquoi celle-ci d'avoir bonjour
frédéric et merci de m'inviter dans
votre émission
avant toute chose pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai choisi cette image j'ai une image
d'actualité puisque c'est une image qui
parle de la pandémie
l'actualité peut-être un petit peu moins
ces derniers temps vu qu'on est en plein
déconfinement mais c'est justement pour
ça que j'ai choisi cette image parce que
je me posais la question de ce qu'il
allait se passer après cette pandémie
est de savoir quelles seront les
conséquences sociologiques et les
conséquences psychologiques sur sur les
pertes sur les gens en fait enfin comme
moi où tout le monde j'ai pas si vous
avez changé depuis la pandémie mais moi
j'ai l'impression que je me sens moins
bien dans les endroits où il ya beaucoup
de monde à présent ya un an et demi est
plus une question sur l'après en fait
oui et vous pensez que pendant longtemps
on va avoir du mal à serrer la main ou à
s'embrasser comme on le faisait
autrefois qu'on va
qu'on veut avoir du mal à quitter nos
basques puisqu'on peut désormais retiré
nos masques en extérieur en france
vous pensez que tout ça ça va ça va ça
va prendre du temps en fait je pense ça
va très individuelle en fait ça va
dépendre des gens bien évidemment je
peux je peux vous dire quelque chose
j'ai remarqué sur sur moi même c'est que
quand je vais au marché faire mon marché
le dimanche matin et qui a des grandes
clés beaucoup de monde partout autour de
moi ça m'importune un petit peu alors
qu'avant c'est quelque chose qu'ils
étaient très banales pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui me
dérange légèrement je sens les gens trop
proche de monde m'a jaune de confort et
de rands 6 qu'ici ça va persister et
bien commençons
[Musique]
kevin bord dit vous êtes donc le
précurseur du live streaming sur les
échecs votre chaîne bitstream a été la
toute première d'abord en anglais puis
en français
elle compte à présent 150 mille abonnés
elle vient d'atteindre 30 millions de
vues vous y jouez presque
quotidiennement tôt échec devant des
milliers de passionnés vous y donner des
master class et vous y commenter en
direct des parties disputées par les
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux
elle a même été pendant une demi heure
je crois lors du dernier tour de l'un
des candidats la chaîne
twitch la plus regardée au monde vous
venez donc de publier avec un autre
joueur d'échecs ami robin un livre pour
les apprentis gagnaire aux échecs
même quand on débute c'est paru chez
aubay que c'est le carton d'audience du
jeu de la dame la serim sur netflix plus
le confinement qui ont fait exploser les
ventes de jeux d'échecs et votre
audience qui vous ont incité à écrire ce
livre de plus en plus de gens ont envie
d'apprendre à jouer aux échecs
oui bah c'est celle éditrice daubé que
kim a qui m'a contacté tout bêtement sur
instagram va envoyer un bm
j'avais l'envié d'écrire un livre mais
je n'y étais jamais trop penché parce
que ça prend beaucoup de temps et c'est
évidemment difficile et elle m'a proposé
ce projet de me dire eh ben voilà il ya
cette nouvelle audience qui arrivent et
les échecs reviennent à la mode et ce
qui serait possible d'écrire un livre
qui s'adresse aux adultes
parce que c'est vrai que ton des livres
pour débuter aux échecs en a beaucoup
qui s'adresse aux enfants de cette idée
de publier un livre et je connaissais sa
me robin qui est un ami qui écrit
extraordinairement bien je trouve
j'ai dit j'ai dit à cette éditrice
écouter allez c'est parti on va tenter
ça et je suis en tout cas
personnellement très heureux du résultat
que ça a donné
et est ce que le jeu de la dame on
n'arrête pas de parler alors ça a été vu
par 62 millions de téléspectateurs dans
le monde sur netflix
alors ça a été vue pendant deux minutes
on sait pas plus fait netflix a
communiqué les chiffres sur les deux
premières minutes si elle 62 millions de
gens qui se sont bien sûr c'est pas si
l'on regardé jusqu'au bout d'abord
est-ce que vous l'avez vue et est ce que
c'est crédible pour un joueur d'échecs
cette série alors j'ai j'ai vu cette
série oui évidemment avec beaucoup
d'intérêt et ce qu'elle est crédible
oui et non comment comment expliquer ça
c'est difficile d'y répondre de manière
directe des jalles et crédible on va
paraître parler sur partir ce qui est
crédible ce qui est crédible c'est la
manière dont on montre les parties
d'échec j'ai trouvé que le lead et
scénaristique de montrer les coûts au
plafond de voir qu'on y pense tout le
temps qu'on étudie les parties ouais ça
c'est très crédible on vit on vit un
petit peu comme ça quand même avec le
jeu d'échecs qui est vraiment au centre
de notre vie et cette idée de tout le
temps vouloir apprendre progresser
analyse et voir les coûts dans sa tête
ça c'est très crédible après pour
obtenir le niveau qu'a obtenus la
joueuse sa demande évidemment un
beaucoup beaucoup plus d'entraînements
que que ce qui a eu et d'être je pense
mieux entouré on a besoin d'être
vraiment entouré par les meilleurs
joueurs du monde pour progresser et les
meilleurs entraîneurs mais en soi pour
un pour un film est tiré d'un roman
c'est quand même assez crédible il ya
des grands films sur les échecs on en
voit sortir de plus en plus ces derniers
temps mais est ce qu est un grand film
pour vous moi je pense à la diagonale du
fou
ah oui avait plus anciens donc oui oui
même après lisbonne sacrifices sur sur
bobby fischer ou d'autres mais moi je
pense que la diagonale du fou alors vous
même kevin bordi vous étiez un joueur
très prometteur vous avez participé vous
avez fait partie de l'équipe de france
jeunes vous êtes participer au
championnat du monde
vous êtes arrivé au classement elo à 200
2274 au point en octobre 2005 vous aviez
18 ans et puis vous avez arrêté de
disputer des parties officielles
pourquoi alors pour deux raisons déjà
première chose je n'avais pas la
capacité de rentrer dans le top 100
mondial des joueurs comme dans beaucoup
de sports en fait on joue quand on est
enfant né dans les meilleurs de son pays
mais malheureusement il ya beaucoup
d'appelés et très peu d'élus et moi on
va dire que j'aurai réussi je sais pas
c'est difficile de parler de soi même et
j'aurais peut-être ai-je été entre
guillemets vers la 1000e ou 5 100e place
mondiale ce qui est pas vraiment
suffisant pour en vivre en tant que
joueur en tout cas pas en tant
qu'entraîneur et la deuxième raison qui
est peut-être la plus importante c'est
que j'ai été passionné par les parties
longues les parties d'échecs sont très
longues en tournoi les parties
compétition dure jusqu'à 6 7 heures
et moi je préfère jouer des parties de
10 de 10 minutes à une heure en fait et
on va voir que c'est passé d'ailleurs
les partis qui ont le plus de succès
aujourd'hui à les parties rapides ou
ultra rapide
il ya quand même une partie qui vous a
rendu célèbre dans le milieu des
passionnés d'échecs
c'est celle que vous avez disputé contre
le champion du monde
magnus carlsen et vous lui avait arraché
une partie nulle alors ça c'est me
placer dans quelles conditions
exactement alors c'est important de
remettre du contexte là dedans gt gt en
vacances au portugal quand j'ai joué ce
tournoi est un tournoi sur internet et
et je revenais de marrakech où je
rencontre un copain à marrakech et il me
dit dans une soirée
il me dit il ya une ouverture qui
s'appelle la grotte qui est la pire
ouverture au monde
y a pas pire que ça et il me dit oui
mais kevin comprend quelque chose quand
tu joues la drogue il ya un esprit qui
fait que ça se passe bien donc j'arrive
au portugal joue ce tournoi en vacances
et puis je lance un petit défi avec le
chat si je joue contre magnus carlsen je
le jouerai une robe parce que il ya le
copain mehdi qui m'a dit qu'à l'esprit
d'un crabe
si on joue ce tournoi première ronde
joue pas contre car la scène je gagne
deuxième je gagne troisième je gagne
quatrième je gagne je fini par gagner
les sept premières parties du tournoi
d'affilée et donc il reste plus que deux
leaders du tournoi magnus et moi j'ai eu
un peu de chance de pas le jour au début
parce que j'étais un peu sur un nuage
je me disais bon ça se passe bien c'est
le destin et donc qui arrive cette
partie et jouent cette grotte donc qui
est la pire ouverture au monde cia peut
pas faire moins bien mais je me dis
c'est l'esprit de la grotte mais dit me
l'a dit la semaine dernière donc tout va
bien se passer
et voilà que finalement la partie ce se
passe très bien et que je fais me nul
donc elle a fait un buzz mondial non
seulement parce qu'il ya un nul contre
carl scène mais aussi parce qu'il ya
cette drogue qui fait que ces noms c'est
nul contre le champion du monde avec la
grotte mais vous vous êtes senti comment
très sincèrement vous fait patienter
contre le champion du monde pour vous
c'est énorme non alors très sincèrement
pont dans la partie j'ai réussi un peu
avec l'expérience à faire le vide dans
ma tête a essayé vraiment de penser
qu'ils étaient nuls réellement parce que
c'est mieux d'être confiants en
cuisinant mais ça va tout se passe bien
il juin gagner cette partie pourquoi pas
lui donc j'ai essayé de rester
consciemment j'ai essayé de rester
cet état d'esprit parce que c'était le
seul état d'esprit qui permettait de
faire une performance
sinon bah c'est juste champion du monde
j'ai peur je tremble et à la fin de la
partie
ces explosions de joie et je me rappelle
avoir dit à ma femme quand je finis la
vidéo je faire le truc m'a fabriqué ce
qui s'est passé je fais une contre le
champion du monde elle réalisé pas trop
en fait elle ne croyait pas faim alizée
pas que c'était passé et et je lui dis
bon ça fera quelques milliers de vues
sur youtube ça va être fantastique et et
j'ai jamais imaginé le poste ça ferait
donc votre femme et russes vous avez
vécu dix ans russie la russie c'est le
sait la patrie des échecs j'aimerais
bien comprendre pourquoi qu'est ce que
ça change de vivre comme dans un pays
comme la russie par rapport à la france
quand on quand on joue aux échecs
sachant que les échecs sont nés ronaldo
6e siècle enviro que
le sujet est arrivé en europe par les
arabes à la fin du 19e siècle
c'est ce qui explique d'ailleurs le
contexte médiéval du jeu d'échecs la
tour le fou le roi la reine
mais pourquoi la russie alors le déjà
pourquoi les échecs sont devenus
populaires en russie
c'est un sujet intéressant en 1924 c'est
pas dire de bêtises il ya un général de
l'armée rouge qui a décidé de créer des
sections d'échecs avec l'idée d'éduquer
le peuple entre guillemets à l'art de la
guerre à la stratégie militaire et le
jeu a rencontré un franc succès et en
1930 il y avait déjà un million de
de russes inscrits dans l'est dans les
sections d'échec parce que ils ont juste
aimé le jeu donc c'est un peu comme ça
que c'est parti historiquement et
ensuite une fois quand on quand on est
en russie évidemment les échecs c'est
quand même un jeu important déjà quand
vous dites que vous êtes joueur d'échecs
en russie on vous demande pas tu fais
quoi comme métier dans la vie il peut
arriver en france
ils ont été joueur d'échecs oui tu fais
quoi voilà non la série qui était joueur
d'échecs à quel niveau c'est plus ça est
ce que tes profs est ce que tes joueurs
mais déjà il ya ce ce respect du joueur
d'échecs et en plus quand on est joueur
d'échecs justement là bas ça permet de
rencontrer tout un tas d'entraîneurs et
de joueurs extraordinaires et de jolies
femmes parce que les lettres joueur
d'échecs en réussissent c'est sexy j'ai
l'impression ouais en russie il ya un
peu de ça
papa que joueur d'échecs en fait en
général tous les métiers genre ouais
profs tous les métiers un peu
intellectuel ça c'est un peu un peu la
classe ouais il y avait ça dans le dans
l'initiative soviétique de rendre les
jeux d'échecs populaire s'était décidé
aussi de développer intellectuellement
le peuple c'est ça alors oui comme ugc
c'est parti d'une idée militaire entre
guillemets pour pour être prêts en cas
de guerre c'est en 1924 donc l'époque
aussi un peu un peu tumultueuse mais où
il ya cette idée de rendre les gens plus
intelligents et et de leur permettre de
comprendre plus de choses et d'avoir des
armes une arme intellectuelle leur
permettant de comprendre des
problématiques quoi est ce que c est ce
que c'est vrai est ce que de jouer aux
échecs ça rend plus intelligent je pense
pas de manière directe non après les
échecs ça peut donner des armes de
réflexion je peux donner un exemple aux
échecs il faut souvent prévoir en avance
c'est un peu un peu le but du jeu c'est
prévoir quelques où on joue nous savoir
ce que l'adversaire va répondre
est ce ce jeu d'échec c'est la façon le
fait de bien jouer aux échecs va
peut-être donner plus de stratégie dans
la vie quand on est face à un problème
est de réussir à plus se poser pour
prévoir en amont comment va le régler en
fait et pas de faire du coup par coup
est-ce qu'à force d'anticiper parce
qu'il faut anticiper tout le temps aux
échecs sk force d'anticiper est-ce qu'on
voit plus loin y compris dans sa vie
est-ce que l'horizon se dégage
moi j'ai la faiblesse de penser que oui
parce que
on va on va sans arrêt essayer de se
mettre un coup plus loin sur ce qui va
se passer je vais faire ça ça va voir
telle conséquence je vais faire si va se
passer telle chose
et une fois que je serai à 7 tev telles
choses là au lieu de s'arrêter là on va
quand même essayer de se dire à ma une
fois que je serai là est ce que ça va me
donner d'autres opportunités puisque ben
je serai dans une impasse
on va on va réellement avoir cette
gymnastique d'esprit de se poser des
questions sans arrêt en fait mais ça
peut être très angoissant mon avis ça
explique pourquoi vous avez du mal à
retourner dans la dans la queue au
marché par exemple parce que vous
anticipez vous voyez les microbes vous
voyez les vous voyez le virus vous voyez
toutes les possibilités qui peut y avoir
de de contracter n'importe quelle
maladie
alors là je suis chaud ça va ça je
voyais mais c'est vrai que par rapport à
ma femme et moi j'étais beaucoup plus
inquiétant il doit y avoir de ça mais
oui mais ça doit vous voyez même image
que je vous ai choisi c'était le coc vis
de la question que je me pose
aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'est ce qui va
se passer cet été c'est quelles vont
être les conséquences sur la population
à moyen terme et une fois qu'on sera
moyen terme si j'ai bien anticiper les
conséquences qu'elle sera qu'est ce que
je dois faire aujourd'hui pour être prêt
demain à ce qui va se passer après
demain il va quand même y avoir un peu
ce cheminement de pensée qui va qui va
arriver oui ça peut être très angoissant
après je pense que c'est très personnel
il ya des gens jeu plutôt de nature
positive qui vont essayer de voir le
positif est tirée des opportunités par
rapport à ça mais messi on s'enferme là
dedans et ça peut ça peut ça peut mener
négatif vous deviez être sur des
charbons ardents pour toute la pandémie
en fonction des des mesures qui étaient
prises ou qui n'étaient pas prises
j'imagine que vous bondi fier sur votre
chaîne chez vous au bo javel et 15 kg de
pâtes à la maison on était très très
bien et avaient les pattes les lentilles
on était tranquille et puis après ça
c'était prévu quand même revenus
revenons aux échecs eux mêmes en tant
que jeu
en 1996 l'ordinateur deep blue réussi à
battre le champion du monde garry
kasparov vous devez avoir 9 ans à
l'époque et
c'est un tremblement de terre non on
savait que ça allait arriver un jour ou
l'autre mais mais le moment où ça arrive
évidemment on se pose beaucoup de
questions notamment simplement sur
l'avenir des échecs est ce que ça va
servir encore à quelque chose d'avoir
des humains qui s'affrontent vu qu'on
est moins fort et est évidemment c'est
une prise de conscience pour tout le
monde puisque par par exemple dans les
années 70 l'ordinateur arrive à peine à
faire nul contre un joueur de club en
l'espace de 20 ans il passe de deux
matches nuls contre 1 contre un joueur
amateur à battre le champion du monde et
évidemment c'est un tremblement terre je
pense qu'il a surtout une inquiétude de
se dire est ce que les échecs gonce
simplement pas s'arrêter à cause de ça
et pourquoi ne sont ils pas arrêter
parce que l'erreur est humaine et qu'en
réalité la beauté des échecs et aussi
dans les erreurs qui sont commises le
problème lorsque vous faites jouer deux
ordinateurs ensemble c'est qui joue
tellement bien
j'ajoute allemand parfaitement qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à se battre donc on est
sûr de la perfection qui est
incompréhensible parce qu'on peut une
partie entre deux êtres humains on
comprend ce qui se passe parce que notre
cerveau nous permet de voir justement
cet horizon de calcul et de comprendre
les concepts stratégiques une partie
entre deux ordinateurs elle est
fondamentalement parfaite ou presque
parfaite
et en plus les concepts des ordinateurs
qui sont jouées sont très difficilement
intellectualise à bhl pour un cerveau
humain ce qui rend ces partis assez
insipide avoir en réalité quand on joue
au poker on joue l'homme où la femme si
on joue contre une femme c'est très
psychologique quand on joue au casino à
la roulette
c'est justement il ya plus psychologie
et hélas ça peut être assez déroutant
pour que pour un joueur de poker par
exemple les échecs c'est quoi on joue
l'homme où on joue là où on joue comme
elle à roulettes sur des probabilités de
l'intelligence purement abstraite alors
on essaye de base de jouer les coups
parfaits on essaye de chercher le coup
parfait sans arrêt donc on va pas penser
en
en termes de kiki et mon adversaire en
face de moi on va juste chercher les
meilleurs cependant il ya surtout à haut
niveau à très haut niveau
les joueurs sont très fort ça sert dans
un mouchoir de poche ils ont à peu près
le même niveau à l'aller carré est très
très faible
mais chaque joueur a des points forts et
des points faibles on sait que tel
joueur et prix fort en tactique tel
joueur est plus fort en finale l'autre
est plus fort en stratégie est donc là
il peut arriver il arrive même assez
fréquemment qui joue qui joue l'homme
qui joue et le fallait il tente si à
deux coups qui semble équivalent de même
force
on va plutôt aller vers le coup qui va
amener une position qui favorise les
joueurs ou l'autre le quine ou favorise
nous en fait par rapport à l'adversaire
donc on peut jouer aussi l'homme aux
échecs même si c'est plus rare depuis
que on s'entraîne contre des ordinateurs
qu'est ce que ça a changé
est ce que le jeu a changé oui le jeu
est en perpétuelle mutation depuis
l'arrivée des ordinateurs puisque les
ordinateurs deviennent de plus en plus
fort donc leur compréhension et est de
plus en plus intéressante pour pour nous
et en fait on va analyser les choix de
l'ordinateur les meilleurs coups de
l'ordinateur pour pouvoir les reproduire
en partie aussi à des concepts que nous
avons pensé vrai on a vérifié avec
l'ordinateur et il s'est trouvé que
c'était faux on a pensé que certaines
stratégies marché donnait un avantage
alors que celle inverse et inversement
il ya certaines stratégies qu'on pensait
plus faible moyenne et qui en fait sont
très fortes
donc aujourd'hui quand on s'entraîne on
s'entraîne vraiment avec l'ordinateur en
essayant à de vérifier que nos idées
sont bonnes et aussi d'aller chercher
ses idées à lui pour les réutiliser dans
nos partis donc les l'ordinateur a
vraiment fait évoluer le jeu il ya il ya
beaucoup d'ouverture qui sont célèbres
échec vous en d'étudier d'ailleurs un
certain nombre dans votre livre vous les
expliquer aux joueurs débutants et vous
leur expliquez comment s'en servir pour
gagner
est-ce que les ordinateurs ou inventer d
ouverture géniale
alors aujourd'hui l'invention des
ouvertures passe obligatoirement par les
ordinateurs
la réponse est clairement oui il ya un
être humain qui est derrière
l'ordinateur qui essayent de choisir les
coups les plus intéressants et c'est en
fouillant
avec l'ordinateur qu'on va on va trouver
le les coups les plus forts on peut dire
que le duo homme ordinateur est
largement plus fort que ordinateur seul
aussi c'est souvent la combinaison de
l'homme avec l'ordinateur qui va trouver
les plus belles idées et que vous savez
pourquoi
simplement ils calculent beaucoup plus
que beaucoup plus vite que nous
l'ordinateur tout mais qu'est ce que
l'homme apporte à l'ordinateur
cette forte si oui en fait l'homme il va
en fait l'ordinateur il va quitter du
calcul pur brut et c'est qu'en fait
c'est là qu'il va calculer à 60 coups à
l'avant s'il va avoir des milliards de
possibilités mais il va donner un
résultat en chiffres en arithmétique à
la fin les blancs sont nuls et blancs
sont moins bien et l'homme il va
apporter à cette créativité se ce sens
de dire oui mais il faut voir encore
plus loin ils ont coordinateur il a il a
une limite et l'homme il peut avoir un
concept en fait est le concept que va
trouver l'homme peut parfois enfin est
parfois plus fort que ce que
l'ordinateur trouvent seuls les les
échecs à quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est qu'un enfant peut battre and adult
une femme peut battre un homme un
employé peut battre son patron et
pourtant moi je trouve ça profondément
injuste c'est que j'ai l'impression que
vous battrez jamais quelqu'un qui a dix
points de plus que vous au cuit
j'ai l'impression que celui qui est plus
intelligente que vous vous battra
toujours est ce que est ce que c'est
vrai alors les échecs c'est vraiment une
intelligence spécifique parce que c'est
un peu ces deux là même enfin séparé ne
m'en rends premiers médias de la mémoire
évidemment parce qu'il faut se rappeler
de ce conte de ce qu'on a vu de ce qu'on
a appris il ya une intelligence visuel
il faut pouvoir bien visualiser comment
les pièces vont bouger dans l'espace et
il ya le calcul calculer ses calculs et
variantes dans la dans la longueur dans
la profondeur si vous avez ces trois
qualités dans votre intelligence
effectivement c'est un grand avantage
sur les autres mais j'ai apprécié aussi
injustes sont des qualités qui font
qu'on a plus ou moins de poids ou cuit
alors on sait bien que là aussi le qi
c'est pas tout l'intelligence c'est pas
non plus toutes les formes
d'intelligence enfin ça compte quand
même on voit bien si vous
si vous êtes fort dans ces trois formes
d'intelligence la wave vous serez très
bon aux échecs vous prendre mon exemple
comme j'ai dit que j'avais arrêté les
échecs que je pouvais pas rentrer dans
le top 100 mondial
on exemple personnel si vous prenez le
numéro un français maxime vachier
lagrave qui a été numéro 2 mondial qui
était un tout petit peu plus jeune que
moi je le connais très bien ça un bon
ami honnêtement c'est impossible pour
moi de calcul est aussi vite que lui je
pourrais faire tout ce que je veux tout
au cours de ma vie maxime calculera
toujours plus vite que moi c'est il ya
il a une formule 1 on est on est on est
en deux chevaux derrière on fait tout ce
qu'on peut on donne le meilleur de nous
mais il calculera toujours plus vite et
vous pourrez vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est profondément injuste ça on
n'arrête pas de dénoncer toutes les
injustices sociales là moi j'aurais
voulu être joueur de rugby si j'avais pu
donc malheureusement j'ai pas une fille
donc là il ya beaucoup d'injustices dans
la vie ce sens je fais partie
d'allemagne a oui c'est vrai magnus
carlsen l'actuel champion du monde
d'ailleurs il jouera sur novembre je
crois contre son challenger
qu'est ce qu'il a de particulier
karl scène i je dirais qu'il a tout il a
tout c'est à dire qu'il a la mémoire il
a le calcul il a le placement pièces
donc ce sont des qualités très
importantes du joueur d'échecs est il à
l'aptitude à beaucoup travailler
donc il réunit toutes les qualités du
joueur d'échecs parfait en fait c'est le
joueur ultime
on peut pas on peut pas réunir plus de
qualités pour être un grand joueur
d'échecs et c'est probablement on le
saura à la fin de sa carrière mais c'est
probablement le plus grand joueur de
tous les temps
il est incroyable plus grand que bobby
fischer plus grands kasparov sais c'est
qu'à me disais pas encore terminé sa
carrière donc c'est dur assez dur à dire
mais il est vraiment incroyable
il est vraiment incroyable comme les
échecs ont évolué c'est sûr qu'ils
étaient plus forts qu'eux puisque ont
progressé au fur et à mesure de
l'histoire des échecs on est de plus en
plus fort moi je trouve que c'est
vraiment un joueur exceptionnel
magnus carlsen fischer il arrêtait très
vite sa carrière après son titre de
champion du monde en 72 il a tout de
suite pris sa retraite
donc c'est il lui manque quand même ce
côté bobby fischer qui est absolument
génial mais du manque ce côté
défense du titre qui est quand même une
phase importante dans la carrière d'un
joueur
kasparov est aussi un joueur
exceptionnel il a été numéro 1 je crois
pendant 18 ans consécutivement donc
c'est incroyable ces files this bat
contre des livres d'histoire là au bout
d'un moment c'est un coin mais carlson
moi je trouve que c'est un vraiment
exceptionnel très complet et et qui
réussit à mettre un écart par rapport au
numéro deux mondial qui est assez
impressionnant
c'est peut-être bobby fischer qui a
popularisé l'idée que un champion du
monde d'échecs est forcément un peu fou
voire carrément ouest il est et il était
bien fou après façon quand on se plonge
autant dans un an dans une matière
intellectuelle que soient les échecs ou
autre chose je tends je pense qu'on a
envie d'un peu dans son monde mais mais
mais c'est normal parce que le temps qui
doit être dépensé pour pour avoir ce
niveau échec ça ça force à penser aux
échecs tout le temps et ça peut donner
cette impression d'être d'être un peu
bizarre mais après les champions du
monde comme kasparov karpov j'ai pu les
rencontrer d'ailleurs ils sont tout à
fait normaux quand vous l'a dit mir
kramis qui sont tout à fait normaux
quand vous discutez avec eux et carlson
aussi j'imagine le connais pas
personnellement carrousel mais pour les
trois autres pour avoir déjà parlé avec
eux ces décès des personnes très
agréable et très cultivé pour les trois
russes carmes scène c'est quand même les
échecs depuis que les échecs ont envahi
internet je propose de faire une pause
kevin bord dit on se retrouve juste
après et on va voir l' influence que les
échecs que l'internet a eu sur les
échecs
on est retour avec kevin bord 10 h and
lead stream mais la chaîne numéro un sur
les échecs en france et il vient de
publier avec sami robin chez eux mais
qu'un livre d'apprentissage pour les
adultes gagner aux échecs même quand on
débute on parlait de d'internet ça fait
ma 20 ans maintenant que les échecs sur
sur internet
qu'est ce que ça a changé jasse a rendu
les échecs et les parties d'échecs en
direct beaucoup plus accessible pour les
amateurs quand j'étais petit on
attendait les magazines des chèques pour
pouvoir rejouer les parties des grands
joueurs à la maison
souvent on connaissait même pas vraiment
les résultats on attendait le début du
mois pour pour feuilleter pour savoir
tient kasparov a joué comme si karpov a
joué comme ça si on regarde la partie je
vais essayer de jouer pareil quand
internet est arrivé ça a permis de
diffuser les tournois d'échecs en direct
sur sur internet
et évidemment c'est c'était une grande
chance c'est exceptionnel pour pour tous
les joueurs de pouvoir assister aux
parties en direct en plus ton à l'étang
de réflexion on voit ce qui se passe ça
déjà ça vraiment démocratiser le
broadcast des échecs des échecs
j'ai l'impression que c'est à partir de
là que internet est un peu le royaume du
public c'est à dire les parties très
rapide
oui dès que les plateformes internet
sont
sont sortis les plateformes pour jouer
en ligne en réalité le dans les clubs
d'échecs ont joué contre jouer des
parties amicales ont joué surtout en
bleed souvent rapide parce qu'évidemment
quand vous venez au club le jeudi soir
après avoir bossé à 19 heures c'est pas
pour faire une partie de six heures donc
évidemment dans les clubs on a tout le
temps jouer en partie rapide ou en
partie blitz et donc avec l'émergence
d'internet va tout un tas de joueurs aux
quatre coins du monde ont pu se
rencontrer entre eux moi j'entends
souvent je discute un peu avec des
amateurs ou des who des élèves et à une
vie assez génial tu imagines ce matin
jouer contre un kazakh le git et à
alma-ata machin on se fait une partie 3
minutes
il ya aussi ce côté là avec les échecs
sur sur internet les échecs en guise de
se dire je me connecte je vous contre un
mec à l'autre boulot dodo de la planète
et je suis capable d'avoir un échange
avec lui parce que les chèques saussines
langues
ceci est comment dire ya un échange qui
se passe quand on fait une partie
d'échecs donc il ya ce côté là et il ya
les parties rapides qui ont pris un
grand un grand essor way avec avec le
jeu sur internet alors est apparue
twitch la plateforme qui permet de
regarder les les meilleurs joueurs
disputer des jeux vidéo en direct
twitch au départ a beaucoup de succès
parce qu'on y regarde les jeux vidéo
mais tout à coup on va y mettre aussi
des chaînes dont la vôtre qui va être la
première d'abord en anglais bleach
stream ou tout à coup on va se servir de
twitch pour les échecs et plus seulement
pour les jeux vidéo qu'est ce qui vous
en a donné l'idée au départ je
regarderai je suivais une chaîne sur
youtube en réalité qui faisait des
partis analyse
tu fais des analyses post post mortem
des parties j'aimais bien un gars qui
s'appelait de chasse network et donc je
me suis dit tiens je vais faire la même
chose non en direct parce que j'aime
bien j'aime bien le direct et donc je me
suis lancée sur cette plateforme et
y'avait il y avait très peu voire pas du
tout deux chaînes d'échecs avait
vraiment 3 4 chaînes il ya des personnes
jugent me lancer là dedans et je faisais
ça en rentrant chez moi le soir j'ai
j'habite à moscou à l'époque je rentrais
le soir vers minuit tu mon boulot et je
me lançais à 00h30 pour envoyer quelques
parties d'échecs l'âge et j'aime bien et
j'ai eu la chance du coup pourquoi j'ai
continué aussi parce que j'ai eu la
chance que ce gars là que je suivais sur
youtube qui s'appelait chess network
fasse un tweet recommandé ma chaîne et à
partir de ce moment là l'histoire était
lancée et comment est-ce que comment est
ce qu ensuite légion quels rapports on
n'entretient plus exactement avec les
gens qui vous regardent
alors en fait je vous parlais du coût de
ce qui s'est passé au tout début parce
que je trouve que c'est un moment
important
c'est l'émoi dans pour ma chaîne c'était
l'esprit du beau jeu c'était envoyer des
belles parties donc c'était d'essayer de
créer un genre on va dire un arrêt chic
et de d'attaqué du et le beau jeu comme
au tennis on jour et service volée
c'était de se dire on va on va se mettre
avec des gens qu'on connaît pas mais ça
à faire voir une bande de potes et on va
essayer d'envoyer des parties où il va
se passer quelque chose de sympa et donc
à on entretient on entretient via le
chat gens mettent à jouer un beau coup
tu aurais pu jouer ça en garde les
parties est et il ya ce ce genre de
cette relation de chercher la beauté
vous cherchez la beauté les bonnes
parties mais en même temps vous
pratiquez notamment sur twitter
enfin le trash talking comment vous le
comment vous expliquez ça est-ce que
c'est pas cohérent alors
non parce que depuis petit j'aime
beaucoup le rap et je suis un fan de rap
fab debout bas j'aime beaucoup ça arrive
et j'aime beaucoup les rap contenders si
vous connaissez wojtek peut-être
d'autres d'autres rappeurs et donc
j'aime j'aime bien le beau mot la bonne
punchline qui fait mal la bla bla beauté
de la petite blague un peu sympa et
et donc il ya ce côté aussi dans les
clubs aux échecs canton blitz avec
quelqu'un qu'on joue à partir peu rapide
un peu ce côté chambrage on aime bien
chambrer l'adversaire on le fait aussi
en club
donc moi c'est vrai que j'ai un peu lié
tout ça allait les belles parties et
puis et puis un peu le trash talk label
label rible le beau mot pour moi ça fait
partie d'un ensemble on peut pratiquer
ça quand on commentait ce qu'on peut le
faire quand on joue est-ce que ça gagne
est ce que est ce que quelque chose
interdite à votre adversaire de parler
pendant que vous réfléchissez un en
tournoi c'est absolument interdit en
partie amicale quand on joue avec un
copain c'est possible de le faire ici
si le pote et est d'accord mais
d'ailleurs ça me semble ça me fait
penser j'ai un j'ai un ami qui un jour
il dit est ce que les échecs sont un
sport ou un art pose cette question
comme ça puis du coup tu sais pas bons
on discute un petit peu et il arrive
avec une idée qui m'a paru fantastique
il m'a dit les échecs c'est un art
martial ceni un sport reste assis quand
même sur sa chaise c'est pas un art non
plus parce qu'on est quand même là pour
gagner on n'est pas là pour faire le
beau jeu forcément il disait c'est qu'un
art martial c'est l'artt c'est un art du
combat en fait il ya un peu de tout il
ya un peu de combat il ya un peu de
sport et un peu d'art donc ça la
frontière de tout ça et du coup je joue
aux échecs en voulant faire des peines
partie on voyait un peu de punch line
c'est un peu comme avant un combat de
boxe
voilà on parle un petit peu et on règle
ça devant l'échiquier donc il ya un peu
de ça est-ce qu'il faut être méchant
pour gagner aux échecs au poker il me
semble qu'il faut être méchant il faut
avoir envie d'anéantir sur l'adversaire
c'est la même chose aux échecs pour pour
moi moi pour faire une bonne partie à
titre personnel j'ai vraiment besoin
d'avoir envie de gagner je suis
incapable si je joue contre un de mes
amis je suis incapable de bien jouer
j'ai pas envie de le battre en fait le
mec est sympa j'ai rigolé avec lui
pourquoi le battre en fait un pur quoi
ça sert à quoi alors oui je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de joueurs qui ont envie
comme ça de s'imposer dr carl scène ça
ça se sent je trouve qu'il a il a cette
envie de gagner tout le temps ça ça sent
il a des explosions de joie même quand
ils voulaient toi sur internet on voyait
bondit sur sa chaise il a cette envie
de l'emporter je pense ça c'est quelque
chose qui drive beaucoup de joueurs
d'échecs
vous avez enseigné les échecs en école
primaire est ce que c'est bon pour les
enfants les échecs
oui je pense que à petites doses a pris
1 pas 10 heures par semaine la petite
dose c'est très intéressant je me
rappelle d'une anecdote dans une classe
je souhaitais en suisse donc ça doit
être l'équivalent du ce1 ou du co2 le
prof d'histoire-géographie était venu me
voir il m'avait dit c'est incroyable
parce que cette année on n'a pas eu
besoin d'expliquer aux élèves comment se
retrouver sur une carte spéciale et les
coordonnées a b c d e sur la carte et un
deux trois quatre cinq six à dix c'est
la première année où le cours a duré 15
minutes
les enfants savent et automatiquement
trouver les monuments sur la carte et
les noter parce qu'il avait appris les
coordonnées en vial vial via le jeu
d'échecs donc c'est un exemple parmi
tant d'autres et un petit texte notre
exemple que kim avait touché d'un point
de vue émotionnel il y avait un petit
enfant dans une classe où j'enseignais
qui était en retard sur les autres au
niveau scolaire et il y avait eu un
énorme changement au cours de l'année la
professeure principale était venu me
voir un glee c'est génial les échecs ça
ça a vraiment poussé ce gamin il était
venu me voir à la fin de l'année et il
m'avait dit merci kevin vous m'avez
redonner confiance en moi je pensais que
j'étais plus bêtes que les autres et
comme je les bats aux échecs à chaque
fois moi j'ai compris qu'en fait c'est
c'était pas le problème et ça avait
complètement relancé cet enfant dans sa
scolarité et ça c'est un cas personnel
mais qui m'avait énormément touché donc
oui je pense les échecs ça peut apporter
et au niveau intellectuel tout bêtement
ou même au niveau de l'estimé de soi
quoi ça peut ça peut apporter des choses
à certains certains enfants on a
l'impression parfois mais c'est
peut-être dans l'ancien monde avant l'
internet
on avait l'impression que les échecs à
isoler ceux qui jouaient ça n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui
non pas du tout au contraire je pense
que ça réunit les gens aujourd'hui les
échecs notamment par internet
quand vous jouez sur internet vous
faites partie d'une communauté vous
discutez des partis etc
c'est plutôt un inquiet que reliant lien
social et comme comme vous le disiez
plutôt que ce soit on joue aux échecs
pareils qu'on essaie tant disant 90 ans
qu'on soit un homme une femme qu'on soit
français kazakh indiens russes
américains c'est le même jeu c'est les
mêmes règles au contraire que sa relique
plutôt les gens mais est ce que ça ne
rend pas obsessionnel ça fait partie de
ces jeux alors les échecs qu'on a
l'impression que c'est c'est le c'est le
comble mais y aller le bridge aussi sarr
obsessionnel le golf un peu obsessionnel
ceux qui jouent les échecs ça doit être
terrible non il faut réussir à trouver
la bonne frontières sef ont peut être
dans la passion des échecs et mais les
échecs et réussir à en sortir mais
effectivement on peut on peut aussi
devenir exception obsessionnel pardon il
pensait tout le temps refuser la défaite
se remettre en cause
intellectuellement comme comme vous le
disiez il ya un rapport avec
l'intelligence quand on perd aux échecs
on se sent plus bêtes que les autres
alors que c'est vraiment vraiment une
intelligence très spécifiques
mais il ya ce côté là et ça ça peut ça
peut aussi rendre rendre optionnel mais
j'ai envie de dire comme beaucoup de
choses dans la vie
j'avais c'est plutôt une attitude
personnelle à entretenir pour rester
dans la passion et pas à partir dans
l'obsession je disais aussi qu'une femme
peut battre un homme
et pourtant il n'ya qu'une femme qui est
rentré dans le top ten mondial c'est
judit polgar qu on avait surnommée la
reine des échecs qui est hongroise elle
a été grand maître un âge elle était
encore plus jeune que ne l'était bobby
fischer quand il l'était devenu grand
maître et pourtant il n'est arrivé que
huitième mondial pourquoi pas première
mondiale hors m'a dit c'est la même
chose au fond entre entre le premier la
8e ils sont dans un mouchoir de poche
mais pourquoi n'y a pas plus de femmes
à très haut niveau dans les échecs
aujourd'hui et pourquoi on continue d'
et pourquoi on continue de faire un
championnat du monde féminin à
championnat à part au fond des hommes
comme si elle ne pouvait pas jouer en
mixte alors déjà pour revenir au niveau
des femmes en premier lieu il ya déjà
beaucoup moins de femmes qui jouent aux
échecs que d'hommes
je n'ai pas la répartition exacte on
doit être aux alentours de 90 10 donc
déjà statistiquement il ya neuf mois à
moins de chance d'avoir une femme qui
arriva à haut niveau
ces catégories féminines elles ont été
créées de mémoire pour encourager
justement la pratique des femmes pour
que les femmes jouent plus qu'elle gagne
des tournois et qu'elle puisse devenir
joueuse d'échecs professionnelles pour
faciliter en fait l'heure leur arrivée
au haut niveau en créant une catégorie
spécifique
après pour moi le fait que judit polgar
soit arrivé numéro 8 mondial ça prouve
que n'importe quelle femme si une y
arriver c'est que n'importe quelle femme
peut y arriver
c'est ça pour moi c'est une évidence de
dire que n'importe quelle femme peut
théoriquement devenir championne du
monde
numéro 8 numéros après il ya des
circonstances de carrière ça joue
vraiment à rien en revanche je dois dire
que judit polgar et ses deux autres
soeurs qui sont toutes devenues de très
fortes joueuses s'étaient pas la plus la
plus talentueuse détroit je crois qu'il
y avait une autre soeur qui était plus
talentueuses chalmé qui n'aimait pas
trop joué il ya qui a quitté les échecs
mais il faut dire que leur leur père qui
les a entraîné intensivement 2d tout
petit
les amis en catégorie mixte directement
il n'est pas passé par par cette
catégorie féminine ou en tout cas très
très jeunes elles ont commencé à jouer
avec les hommes et j'ai l'impression que
bon déjà donc il ya ce problème de
pourcentage d'hommes qui est bien
supérieur et aussi le fait de devoir se
battre pour une catégorie qui est moins
forte à c'est peut-être moins stimulant
sacré - d'émulation on a besoin
d'arriver - o pour y arriver
et peut-être que c'est un autre facteur
qui joue j'imagine personnellement tient
mélange de plusieurs petits facteurs
comme ces deux là qui font que les
femmes sont moins fortes que les hameaux
et chaque mais comment une stagnation
comment justifient l'existence du
championnat du monde féminin c'est
justement pour les encourager pour leur
deuil pour canada pour qu'elle est elle
donne à brive mais peut-être qu'au fond
ça les disqualifie par rapport au vrai
championnat qu'est celui avec les hommes
contre les hommes c'est tout le dilemme
en fait c est ce qu il faudrait mieux
enlever la catégorie féminine pour
qu'elles jouent tous dans catégorie
mixte espérer qu'ils aient des femmes
qui émergent mais dans ces cas là
peut-être y aurait moins de femmes qui
jouerait il ya aussi la problématique
des femmes qui aujourd'hui sont
professionnels et donc si on enlevait la
catégorie féminine bas ont leur
enlèverait leur travail entre kim et
puisqu'elle pourrait pas vraiment
rivaliser dans le domaines des hommes
donc c'est un con c'est un problème très
complexe et c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'enlever la catégorie
féminine pour pour les raisons que j'ai
cité avant donc c'est un genre de
problème il explique c'est un peu la
foule à poullan fait escale sont moins
forts parce qu'on a créé ce qu'elle joue
plus ou moins c'est un problème vraiment
complexe mais j'espère vraiment qu'il ya
l'émergence d'une femme comme judit
polgar qui réussissent à casser les
codes de nouveau et à y arriver au top
niveau
magnus carlsen le champion du monde qui
est norvégien on l'a pas dit mais
accompli une petite révolution en
lançant son circuit en ligne le magnus
carlsen chez stock
au début c'était quatre tournois avec
des prix d'un million de dollars
c'est une belle dotation quand même
quelques tournois par an je crois que là
ça va être ce qu'il en soit six ou huit
alors qu'est ce que ça a changé ça
qu'est ce que c'est en train de changer
ça va peut-être faire rentrer les échecs
dans les sports à
donc c'est complètement dématérialisé
c'est la première fois qu'on a dans
l'histoire qu'on a des tournois d'échecs
avec de tels prix ça existe un petit peu
avant il y avait beaucoup moins d'argent
donc ça permet d'avoir des déjà plus
souvent des tournois c'est plus facile à
organiser
c'est entre guillemets dans l'air du
temps puisque les échecs c'est quand
même là encore ça se pratique beaucoup
sur internet donc ce côté un petit peu
esport n'importe qui peut y participer
n'importe qui peut théoriquement devenir
fort c'est assez génial et ça attire le
public après
ça pose aussi la question aux
fédérations internationales et aux
instances au niveau de l'arbitrage
comment comment on va faire pour réussir
à rendre ses échecs sur internet entre
guillemets professionnelle parce
qu'actuellement il est très difficile
d'être sûr que toutes les conditions de
fair play soit soient remplies par les
joueurs qui sont même si son film et qui
restent seuls chez eux dans une pièce
connaissant la nature humaine
vous voulez dire que l'on peut tricher
quand on dispute une partie en ligne
plus facilement que quand on dispute une
partie en présentiel comme on dit
aujourd'hui
ah oui c'est forcément plus facile n'y a
pas de détecteur de métaux pour vérifier
s'il n'y a pas un appareil électronique
sur soi donc effectivement c'est un vrai
problème qui pour le moment n'est née
commence à être traités par la
fédération internationale qui a créé un
genre de deux parties homologué hybride
avec parties à domicile mais avec
obligation d'avoir un arbitre chez soi
donc ça commence à évoluer mais on en
est aux balbutiements des échecs en
temps qu'ils se portent sur internet
j'espère réellement que ça va se
développer parce que sa star offre
énormément d'opportunités
alors moi j'ai l'impression que c'est là
où ça offre d'abord des opportunités
c'est à magnus carlsen lui même
j'ai l'impression que au fond quand on
est un joueur quand on est champion du
monde on dispute son le son titre on
leur met en lice tous les deux ans et
est au fond n'est pas très connu il ya
on parle de vous que tous les deux en
quoi quand vous êtes un match là tout
d'un coup ça c'est ça devient il ya des
matches il ya des tournois et des matchs
de façon régulière toute l'année et ça
permet de ça vous rend plus célèbres et
par la même occasion ça vous permet de
gagner plus d'argent
oui tout à fait il ya des tournois
en il ya un circuit un de tournois réels
dont il n'avait pas lieu l'an dernier à
cause du coc vide et c'est pour ça qu'il
ya eu aussi cette émergence des tournois
sur internet
mais c'est vrai que les tournois qui
sont tout au long de l'année sont des
tournois en partie longue donc en partie
classique qui sont moins populaires
auprès du public et qui font moins de
moins de bruit en moins de buzz c'est
vrai que le fait de jouer sur internet
c'est c'est plus dans dans l'air de
twitch quand on a parlé avant les échecs
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup regardé sur
youtube sur sur twitch globalement sur
internet et donc le fait de faire ces
tournois sur internet
ça fait plus parler il ya plus de fans
ya plus de public ils sont
il y en a plus au site ces tournois là
eh oui clairement ça ça donne de la
visibilité aux échecs après il va aussi
falloir entre guillemets transformer
l'essai et réussir à faire des
compétitions qui est aussi un enjeu
sportif parce que pour le moment
à la vue de l'absence de règles claires
ça reste des tournois exhibition entre
guillemets réussir un petit peu à réunir
tout ça et il ya continuer dans cette
voie là qui me semble juste
en réussissant à créer un de réelle
compétition avec un vrai intérêt sportif
sur votre chaîne blip stream vous
commenter des matchs en direct
c'est même devenu votre spécialité vous
l'avez fait même sur l'équipe de
télévision vous avez commenté des
matches là dessus comment c'est c'est
quasiment un métier que vous avez
inventé ça rhône ou ne commentait pas
les matches avant les matchs des chèques
en les commentaires en tout cas c'est
pas comme je le fais moire est
différemment
moi je suis parti du principe en fait
mon style est vraiment simple à
expliquer je pars du principe que les
gens ne regardez pas les échecs mais
écoutez les échecs un petit peu comme
une émission radio donc je me suis plus
s'inspirer de la radio que j'écoute est
gamin que j'écoutais les matches avec
saccomano qui acquit jeune sakho qui
commentait les matchs de football et je
me suis faut commenter les échecs pareil
parce qu'au final
quand vous écoutez un match à la radio
vous avez l'impression qu'ils aient une
occasion de but toutes les deux minutes
quand il ya une frappe de 40 mètres on a
l'impression qu'elle est lucarne on voit
le match à la télé en même temps l etat
les six mètres au dessus et je me suis
dit
il faut commenter les échecs pareil
quand il va y avoir un coût qui va être
joué ça va pas être cavalière trois sets
le cavalier qui arrive en f3 qui
contrôle les quatre centrales le joueur
champion du monde bat news parle scène
met la pression à son adversaire il va
mener une attaque allait droit mais son
adversaire contre attaque à l dame qui
va qui va remporter le duel qui va aller
le plus vite je me suis dit que si on
commande ça dans l'esprit de se dire
qu'on commenté sans l'image mais juste
avec le son bah ça donnerait quelque
chose de beaucoup plus vivant est
beaucoup plus intéressant pour les gens
et beaucoup plus dans l'air du temps
aussi parce que finalement j'imagine
qu'au lancement il ya des gens qui
écoutent russia today mais qu'il écoute
sur youtube en font avec les écouteurs
dans le métro où je sais pas où mais qui
regarde pas l'image réellement et je
suis partie de ce principe là pour
commenter des parties d'échecs is a créé
un style quoi mais en même temps est-ce
que ça n'était pas trahir le jeu qui est
très cérébral ces deux mois qu'on puisse
dire les échecs et vous en avez fait un
truc justement plus proche du football
au fond ouais mais je suis parti sur sur
l'émotion en fait parce que les échecs
se transmet une émotion et moi cette
émotion quand je vois un cavalier qui
part en f3 ou quoi je vais la vois pas
ce que je vais voir les coûts qui vont
se passer je vais je vais imaginer ce
qui se passe mais en fait pour
transmettre cette émotion je me dis que
le meilleur moyen c'est c'était de
l'image est entre guillemets c'était
c'était de la métamorphoser pour réussir
à retranscrire si on pouvait ressentir
quand on était bons aux échecs mais
d'une manière intelligible et digestible
pour pour les auditeurs ont fait c'est
vraiment une vulgarisation quoi au fond
la leçon des échecs c'est que tout a des
conséquences
quoi qu'on fasse le moindre geste ça
aura une conséquence dans l'avenir non
exactement rennes forcément chaque fois
une conséquence on peut jamais revenir
en arrière c'est fait c'est fait jetons
horrible ouais c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles j'aime pas trop les
parties longues ça me ça me désespère de
passer six heures devant une partie de
faire une erreur stupide après 5h 45 qui
changent le cours d'une partie
c'était trop pesant pour moi
psychologiquement c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on aime bien les blitz parce que - la
conséquence elle peut elle peut partir
sur sur la partie d'après quoi
recommencer du début
et est ce que est ce que ça aide
dans la vie on compte
justement que tout le moindre geste aura
des conséquences qu'on peut pas revenir
en arrière que il faut anticiper en
permanence
est ce que est ce que de jouer aux
échecs ça vous aide dans votre vie vous
ah ouais bah ça permet de se dire qu'il
faut mieux réfléchir avant de parler 10
chars une fois qu'on commence à dire
quelque chose bas il va falloir en
assumer les conséquences qu'on écrit
quelque chose
donc oui ça permet d'être plus posé et
de prendre des décisions de prendre son
temps pour prendre une décision parce
que le prix du lait le coup d'une
décision peut être assez assez grand ça
permet de bien se poser de réfléchir en
toute situation
en essayant on peut devenir pro castille
nateur aussi ne plus prendre aucune
décision
ouais on peut aussi trop
intellectualiser partir dans l'excès
inverse souhaite voir et vouloir tout
tout contrôler en fait les échecs les
joueurs d'échecs parfois peuvent avoir
ce défaut de vouloir tout le temps être
en contrôle de pouvoir vraiment
contrôler une situation à 100% avoir le
contrôle je dirais c'est vraiment ce qui
peut nous caractérisé mais aussi parce
que le jeu d'échecs par définition on
dirait qu'il a aboli le hasard et oui
non en fait quand on est vraiment forts
on voit plus de hasard que quand on
l'est moins en réalité parce qu'on a je
vous avais parlé tard quand on a disputé
les ordinateurs que les ordinateurs
avaient un horizon qui pouvait voir que
50 ou 60 cours à la baisse en calculant
des milliards de possibilités et aux
échecs après quand on devient fou plus
fort on se rend compte qu'on va rentrer
dans une variante on peut en calcul les
conséquences jusqu'à un certain moment
donné mais il ya un moment donné en fait
on ne peut pas avoir le cerveau humain
permet pas de calculer plus vite et ce
qui arrive dans cette position parfois
les deux joueurs ont exactement la même
variante en tête ils ont la même
évaluation de la position qui arrive par
exemple on dit variantes de huit coups
on rentre là dans les blancs sont mieux
le joueur avec les blancs se dit oui bon
bah je vais être mieux en dedans le jour
avec les noix on va dire que j'ai pas le
choix toute façon je suis obligé de
rentrer là dedans donc les deux joueurs
sont absolument d'accord sur tout et il
se trouve que huitième coup donc là où
la position s'est arrêté il y avait ce
que nous on va après une pointe dans le
langage échiquéen un coût qui était très
dur à voir avec les deux ont raté parce
que c'était trop dur et la pointe va
inverser
l'évaluation de la position qui va
passer de mieux au blanc a mis au noir
et ce genre de choses arrive beaucoup
plus souvent qu'on imagine dans les
parties d'échecs
donc en réalité quand on devient plutôt
fort on se rend compte qu'il ya une
certaine partie de hasard dans les
parties d'échecs
on al'impression qu'avec avec twitch et
avec les chaînes comme la vôtre comme
blitz stream
on va voir des ddd gloire amateurs on a
l'impression d'aider des joueurs qui
sont pas dans le circuit mais qui vont
tout à coup devenir connus célèbre comco
comme c'est arrivé pour les joueurs de
jeux vidéo est ce que vous pensez aussi
à wil et les influenceurs entre
guillemets streamer sur tweets et les
plus connus la plupart sont des joueurs
amateurs comme moi alors vite
la plupart ont à peu près le même profil
il était comme moi très fort en
catégorie jeunes à un certain degré ils
ont plus ou moins arrêter la compétition
et ils sont des bon vulgarisateur entre
guillemets du jeu d'échecs mais sans
être de très grands joueurs veut dire
que l'exception à la règle c'est
d'ailleurs le plus gros streamer au
monde hikaru nakamura qui lui a été
numéro 2 mondial et qui est le plus gros
streamer des châteaux au monde mais
messi n'ont la plupart de mes autres
collègues ont un profil similaire au
mien vous imaginiez une fois que vous
avez arrêté les échelles vous imaginiez
faire autre chose dans votre vie que de
jouer aux échecs
parce que même si vous avez arrêté les
parties vous avez continué de jouer aux
échecs et vous n'avez jamais travaillé
que dans les échecs commerciaux
ouais non quand je suis parti vivre en
russie j'ai eu j'ai une petite
parenthèse dans la vie de quelques
années où j'étais rouge et or des échecs
j'ai travaillé dans de divers divers
milieux différents et
et en fait je me suis rendu compte
maintenant à postériori qu en fait
j'avais j'ai deux passions dans la vie
j'aime beaucoup les vidéos à beaucoup
faire des vidéos et parler en live et
j'aime beaucoup les échecs donc pour moi
c'est une chance extraordinaire j'ai
réussi à allier mes deux passions mais
j'ai eu du temps à me à me trouver parce
que j'avais ce souci des parties longues
qui moi me plaisent pas donc comme tout
le circuit professionnel est en partie
longue ça m'a entre guillemets obligé à
sortir des échecs en espérant pouvoir y
revenir d'une autre manière
merci kevin bordi d'avoir passé toute
cette émission avec nous votre livre
s'intitule gagner aux échecs même quand
on débute il est paru chez robeco et
puis votre votre chaîne s'appelle
bitstream
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]